bonjour et bienvenue dans cette option
si nous allons aujourd'hui vous parler
du plus gros dinosaure ayant jamais vécu
ou du moins celui pour lequel les
estimations de poids les plus folles
vente été avancée et ce dinosaure c'est
l'argentinosaurus sans le séisme aux
origines non plus n'ont en fils elias
toujours pas j'epère aurait selon la
cellule trazom rousse et puis et brute à
caiozo rue c'est le coin le brute a raio
aux russes non non non c'est pas lui bon
je ne veux pas enchaîné là où tu as
encore d'autres bêtises aliens non le
plus gros poids jamais estimé pour un
dinosaure est attribuée au rafiot zolis
requis aux russes n'est pourtant pas la
star des top 10 des plus gros dinosaures
il arrive bon dernier sur celui de
wikipédia et ne figure même pas sur bon
nombre d'autres classements
il a certes pendant attendu son heure de
gloire mais il est à présent considéré
comme un membre de taille relativement
modeste de la famille des braqueuses
rider mais bon en matière d'information
fiable se fier à des top 10 des plus
gros dinosaures sur le net et dans la
presse pour enfants et qui soit dit en
passant comporte neuf fois sur 10 des
espèces qui ne sont pas des dinosaures
vous ne serez pas étonné d'apprendre que
ce camp vous y est tout à fait
discutable et ce pour une raison
fondamentalement très simple
la vraie question l'authentic challenge
le défi ultime n'est pas de savoir quel
est le plus gros dinosaures mais bien de
se demander comment par toutatis fait-on
pour peser les plus gros dinosaures quoi
que dis-tu acharné consommateurs de
classement de gigantesques les animaux
préhistoriques
tu ne t'étais jamais posé la question de
comment faire monter une espèce éteinte
sur une balance tu ne vais pas
âgé que le fait de n'avoir que des homos
et fossilisés pouvait être une limite à
notre capacité à déterminer le poids
d'un animal disparu depuis des dizaines
de millions d'années et bien c'en est
une
sachez qu'à l'heure où on vous parle les
paléontologues ce livre par articles
interposés une dispute cordiale mais
ferme quant à l'estimation du poids du
dodo les tenants du 2 2 nuls affrontent
les défenseurs du graphiste ou feint
lespwa calculé variant du simple au
double et là il ne s'agit que d'une
espèce disparue il ya à peine quelques
siècles
il existe des oiseaux de taille
similaire aujourd'hui qu'on peut faire
monter sur une balance
maintenant imaginez pour un dinosaure
sauropode dont il n'existe qu'un
l'équivalent actuel comment vous faites
il n'existe rien de comparable
aujourd'hui à part les baleines qui par
souci d' hydrodynamisme n'ont pas du
tout la même silhouette et qui grâce à
la poussée d'archimède exercée par lots
n'ont pas non plus les mêmes contraintes
a supporté alors comparé les détails
c'est facile mais ce n'est pas parce
qu'un dinosaure fait la même longueur
qu'une baleine bleue qui pèsera le même
poids à longueur égale il ne fait aucun
doute qu'une baleine sera plus lourde
que n'importe quel dinosaures vie tout à
fait entre nous même si on comparait les
dinosaures sauropodes aux baleines
avez vous seulement la moindre idée d'à
quel point il est difficile de peser une
baleine bleue je pense que c'est
maintenant clair dire qu'elle dinosaures
était le plus gros n'est pas une mince
affaire
heureusement cela ne condamne pas à une
éternelle ignorance les scientifiques
sont très intéressés par la question du
poids des dinosaures particulièrement
des sauropodes et pas simplement pour
savoir lequel était le plus gros en
effet les sauropodes qui sont les plus
gros animaux terrestres à avoir existé
ont cette particularité d'être devenu
tellement gros qu'aujourd'hui il
n'existe plus aucun animal terrestre qui
leur arrive à la cheville
et cela a la fâcheuse tendance à irriter
les paléontologues qui aimerait bien
comprendre comment ces animaux dont la
taille dépasse l'entendement arriver à
vivre et ont même réussi à 2000 et
pendant plusieurs millions d'années les
écosystèmes terrestres en crachant au
visage des lois de la physique n'est
plus élémentaires
quelle quantité de nourriture devaient
t-il ingurgité et il a le sang chaud à
sang froid ou bien gigan totet remet
combien d'années pouvait-il vivre
comment positive pour s'accoupler
à quelle vitesse marché dit il
pouvait-il se dresser sur la tête de
derrière toutes sont autant de questions
dont la réponse pourrait être très
différente selon que
dino pèse le poids d'une baleine bleue
ou d'un éléphant et c'est bien pour cela
que les débats autour de ces questions
sont aussi houleux et que les opinions
des scientifiques change sans arrêt
c'est donc dans l'optique de répondre à
ces questions fascinantes que les
paléontologues ont mis au point tout un
tas de techniques plus ou moins
rigoureuses afin d'estimer le poids d'un
dinosaure ainsi plutôt qu'à classement
des plus gros dinosaures nous vous
proposons ici un petit florilège des
techniques qui ont été employés par le
passé si on prend le 15 aux russes afin
d'en estimer le poids vous verrez que ça
vaut son pesant d'or pourquoi
brachiosaures us plutôt qu'un autre
et bien simplement parce que depuis sa
découverte à la fin du 19e siècle et
jusque dans les années 90 brachiosaures
russe a été considéré comme le plus
grand dinosaure connu par des restes
squelettiques substantielle ainsi
pendant tout ce siècle de règne
quasiment toutes les techniques
permettant aujourd'hui de mesurer la
taille d'un dinosaure lui ont été
appliqués quand elles n'ont pas
directement été inventé spécialement
pour lui brachiosaures russe est
certainement le dinosaure dont on a le
plus souvent tentés d'estimer le poids à
ce propos les aficionados de la
paléontologie savent que braqueur aux
russes a été séparée en deux genres
distincts correspondant chacun aux deux
seul squelette connu brachiosaures us le
squelette américain et girafes à titan
le squelette africain brachiosaures
russe serait un poil plus gros aurait le
torse plus long et or et les bras plus
écarter que girafe à titan nous
considérons néanmoins dans cette vidéo
que girafe à titan est braquée joris ne
font qu'un pas seulement parce que ça
nous arrange mais surtout parce que bien
que cette distinction et rencontré
beaucoup d'adeptes sur internet depuis
qu'elle a été proposée en 1988 puis re
proposer en 2009 elle n'a toujours pas
fait l'unanimité parmi les spécialistes
en l'occurrence ces derniers utilisent
encore la plupart du temps le terme
brachiosaures us pour parler
indistinctement des brachiosaures
américains et africains ainsi les
estimations de poids du brachiosaure ont
été faites à partir des squelettes nord
américains ou africains sans distinction
est appliquée au jean prat qui autorise
dans son ensemble pendant plus de 100
ans
les deux ont largement été confondus au
fil des années et l'anatomie de la a
souvent servi de repère afin
d'identifier les fossiles appartenant à
l'autre et vice versa ce qui fait que
l'un et l'autre sont inextricablement
liées est aussi inclus au sein de
braquet aux russes le genre désormais
non valides ultra zorros en effet ultra
zorros qui s'appelait une 13e rue
avant qu'on ne se rendre compte qu'un
autre dinosaure sud-coréen s'appelait
déjà comme ça est un brachiosaure nord
américains connus par un simple aux de
l'épaule
trop peu pour faire de lui un genre à
part entière attention il ne faut pas
confondre ultra zorros avec super aux
russes qui lui il n'appartient pas à la
famille des braqueurs mais à celle du
diplodocus
rien à voir donc pour résumer on va
faire simple pour notre propos
aujourd'hui on va suivre l'avis de la
majorité des paléontologues
et dire que bras qui osent horus girafe
à titan est ultra zorros c'est la même
chose c'est juste du braquet aux eaux
russes et vous allez voir que ce sera
déjà bien assez compliqué comme ça
numéro un la méthode la plus simple
ayant été employé pour estimer la taille
de brachiosaures c'est la naseaux visio
maîtrise quoi bananas ovidio maîtrise
aussi appelé héros gâteau mettrie du la
targa tout mais qui signifie louche
c'est la mesure à la louche
à vue de nez l'estimation grosso modo
bref c'est le pifomètre
il faut reconnaître aux paléontologues
une certaine expertise en matière de
taille de dinosaures et avec un peu de
bon sens et de l'expérience ils peuvent
aux deux vaches près estimer la taille
de n'importe lequel de leurs animaux les
exemples de sauropodes dont les restes
sont trop fragmentaires afin d'estimer
leur poids autrement qu au pifomètre
sont nombreux comptant parmi les plus
grands se reposer id on essaie 40 à 50
tonnes et les 59 tonnes du paralytique
en salaire très précis comme ça 59
tonnes mais en fait c'est du pifomètre
et de temps en temps les expertises
laisse place à la fantaisie et c'est
ainsi que durant les années 80
l'imagination des paléontologues s'est
enflammé et a été emporté vers de
vertigineux sommet à la découverte du
l'ultra zorros l'impression de
gigantisme donnée par cette hausse de
l'épaule et de quelques autres fragments
associés qui se sont avérées e
appartenir à super aux russes en fait à
pousser les scientifiques a avancé le
chiffre délirant de 150 à 180 d'eton
c'est près de deux à trois fois le poids
supposé d'argentine aux eaux russes est
rien de moins que le poids de 30 à 40
éléphants à titre indicatif les baleines
bleues les plus lourdes jamais repêché
faisait autour de 200 tonnes imaginez ce
genre de colosses tenir sur quatre
pattes
néanmoins les pôles de l'ultra zorros
s'est avérée n'être pas aussi grande
qu'on imaginait et elle aurait appartenu
à un individu de taille plutôt
raisonnable pour un brachiosaure de
l'ordre de 40 ou 50 tonnes bien que basé
sur rien de très concret le chiffre de
190 tonnes a néanmoins permis aux
braqueurs de faire son entrée dans le
guiness book des records entre 1986 et
1989 plus jamais après cela on imaginera
qu'un dinosaure puisse avoir été aussi
lourd durant les années 90 des
paléontologues et les physiciens sont
tombés d'accord sur le fait qu'il serait
fortement improbable qu'un animal
terrestre
et puis dépassé les 100 tonnes les
estimations ont donc été revues à la
baisse
mais brachiosaures demeurera pour
toujours le dinosaure au poids le plus
lourd jamais envisagé vous voyez qu'on
ne vous avait pas menti
la première technique avoir été inventé
afin de véritablement estimer le poids
d'un dinosaure et celle du déplacement
d'eau les animaux sont faits en grande
majorité d'eau et par conséquent il
suffit de mesurer quelle quantité d'eau
soulève le modèle réduit d'un dinosaure
dans un récipient pour connaître le
volume de ce modèle réduit et d'en
déduire le poids du modèle d'origine en
le remettant à la bonne échelle quoi si
tous plus le jouet dinosaure un produit
en croix et basterds et ça sonne pas
très pro tout ça oui je sais on n'a pas
inventé grand chose dans le domaine
depuis archimède c'est sûr mais vous
pouvez vérifier que ça marche pas si mal
que ça en allant voir cette vidéo qui
vous apprendra en détail comment
reproduire vous même cette expérience et
si vous n'aimez pas l'eau vous pouvez
faire ça aussi en du sable ou des
graines de moutarde à condition de
connaître leur densité
de plus contrairement au pifomètre cette
technique al'avantage de ne pas
seulement se baser sur les restes osseux
mais de tenir compte de la chair et de
la peau qui recouvre les eaux évidemment
cela rend cette technique très sensible
à la qualité de la figurine que vous
allez utiliser le
vous dit non en mousse n'est pas
recommandé c'est pourquoi en utilisant
la technique du déplacement d'eau avec
du sable pour la première fois sur
braqueuses auris en 1962 un modèle
réduit a spécialement été sculptée pour
l'occasion sous la direction les
paléontologues au plus proche des
connaissances de l'époque
elle a révélé que braqueuses russe
devait peser aux alentours de 78 cette
estimation de poids la première en son
genre fut certainement la plus marquante
a fait date dans la communauté
scientifique et a été omniprésente
pendant plus de vingt ans c'était partir
de cette masse canonique que l'ultra the
rose fut lui-même surestimer ce n'est
qu'à la fin des années 80 et durant les
années 90 que de nouvelles mesures
faites avec des modèles réduits de
brachiosaures plus svelte et plus
conformes en connaissances actuelles
vont ramener son poids à une valeur plus
acceptable de l'ordre de 30 à 40 tonnes
ohwawa savalas avec la même méthode de
mesure qui obtient un point entre 30 et
80 tonnes avait savalas ya de la marge
c'est bien ce que je disais c'est pas
très sérieux tout ça
calmons nous ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'en 1962 la méthode du déplacement
d'eau étaient déjà utilisés depuis 1905
à l'époque elle avait permis d'estimer
le poids de brontosaure us à une valeur
de 30 et une tonne c'est à dire tout à
fait proche de ce qu'on estime encore
aujourd'hui être le poids de cet animal
n'avait donc pas de raison de
s'inquiéter pour le brachiosaure us
enfin si tu le permets c'est moi qui
l'ait prendre la suite du programme non
parce qu'entre le pifomètre est le plus
pluvieux joue les gens commencent
vraiment à se demander quand est ce
qu'on fait de la vraie science dans cet
épisode alors c'est l'heure maintenant
de la technique numéro 3 la double
intégration graphique c'est vrai que ça
nous tout de suite beaucoup plus
scientifique quand ça finit en ique
ouais mais ne t'en fais pas derrière ce
terme barbare se cache un principe
immuable en simple les dinosaures sont
des objets en trois dimensions la
totalité de leur surface peut donc être
réduite à trois faces une vue de côté
une vue de dessus et une vue de face
avec ses trois face il n'y a pas un
centimètre carré de peau de braquer ou
qui nous échappe
il devient alors possible de ramener les
trois dimensions de votre brachiosaures
à celles des trois dimensions by cube et
de calculer le volume de ce cube en
considérant que la surface de ses faces
est la même que celle du bras que genre
dont vous voulez estimer le poids c'est
comme calculer directement le volume
d'un cube mai
d'un cube aux dimensions brachiosaures
yens le point peut être directement
déduit dix volumes par simple
multiplication avec l'intensité de votre
choix
généralement celle de l'eau et si vous
êtes un peu flemmard vous pouvez
n'utiliser que deux phases de votre bras
kyo et considérer que ce n'est pas un
cube mais un cylindre au moins avec
cette technique on peut commencer à
parler sérieusement puisqu'elle donne
des poids beaucoup plus léger et donc
biologiquement plus probable de l'ordre
de 25 à 30 tonnes
oui mais alors si je n'ai qu'à petits
morceaux de fossiles et pas à ce que
laisse entiers qui me permettent de
dessiner une belle silhouette comme
celle là
alors dans ce cas ce qu'il te faut c'est
la technique numéro 4 la droite de
régression ou régression linéaire
régression non mais j'ai pas envie de
régresser moi qui te parle de régresser
et puis tu vas voir c'est très facile
prenons un fémur de brachiosaure et
faisons comme si on ne connaissait pas
le reste du squelette un fémur doit être
capable de soutenir le poids de tout ton
animal en fait un quart de son poids car
il à quatre pattes plus la circonférence
de ton os va jouer un rôle primordial là
dedans comme pour les colonnes dans un
temple grec plus le temple sera lourd
plus la circonférence des colonnes
devrait être grande pour le soutenir
on ne soutient pas un temple avec des
fétus de paille par conséquent il est
raisonnable de penser que la
circonférence du fémur de ton animal
sera proportionnel au point qu'il a dû
supporter jadis et pour déterminer quel
est ce poids il suffit de regarder les
animaux actuels girafes éléphants
crocodiles tortues géantes varans de
komodo sont autant d'animaux géant qui
permettent de savoir comment la
circonférence du fémur varie avec le
poids d'un animal un rein et après ça il
suffit de mesurer la circonférence du
fémur de brachiosaure et d'en déduire
tout bêtement la masse correspondante
c'est vraiment aussi facile que ça oui
et c'est grâce à cette méthode qui ne
nécessite que peu de mesures et qui ne
requiert pas de squelette complet
qu'elle a été possible d'estimer les
masses des dinosaures géants
sud-américains parmi les plus gros du
monde car leurs restes sont souvent
fragmentaires difficile à déplacer et
encore plus à examiner grâce à cette
méthode l'argentinosaurus s'est révélé
peser autour de 73 tonnes c'est à peu
près autant que l'un de ses très proches
cousins argentin lui aussi découvert
très récemment et pas encore nommés dont
l'analyse préliminaire a montré qu'il
avoisiner les 70 tonnes ah oui et
puisqu'on parle des plus gros dinosaures
du monde tâche et d'oublier séisme aux
russes brouillade caiozo russe et en
fils elias même s'ils ont tous été
chiffré à plus de 100 tonnes
bg
parce que 100 tonnes semble être
anatomiquement parlant un maximum
difficile à dépasser ce qui rend ces
estimations douteuses et aussi parce que
de toutes façons ces gens ne sont connus
que par des reste très fragmentaire
réattribué à diplodocus dans le cas de
séisme aux russes voire même
complètement perdu dans les cas de
brouillard kaiser us et en fils elias
ces dinosaures n'existe donc plus aux
yeux de la science l'autre avantage de
cette méthode c'est que des droite de
régression peuvent être tracés à partir
de n'importe quelle mesure d'à peu près
tous les os des pattes c'est ainsi qu'on
a pu estimer la taille de dinosaures
connues uniquement par quelques restent
isolés ou encore non étudiées comme le
nouveau se repose d'angeac charente dont
la longueur du fémur correspondrait à un
animal d'une quarantaine de tonnes
appliquée aux empreintes de dinosaures
de plagne sait si on peut faire ça aussi
il est possible de dire que ces traces
de un mètre cinquante de diamètre aurait
pu être produites par les pas d'un
dinosaure avoisinant les 100 tonnes les
fameuses 100 tonnes ce serait lui le
plus gros dinosaures alors oui oui mais
il ya forcément à mais elle a marre de
tes mais il faut toujours que tu dises
qui armé mais si je le dis c'est bien
parce que c'est vrai mais cette méthode
a ses limites dans lequel ils braquaient
aux russes la mesure de la circonférence
du fémur a donné des résultats tantôt de
l'ordre de 30 tonnes tantôt des mesures
beaucoup plus basses descendant jusqu'à
16 tonnes et même seulement 13 tonnes
pour vous donner une idée de ce que cela
représente les plus gros éléphant mâle
qui était pesé faisait aux alentours de
12 tonnes
c'est seulement une à quatre tonnes de
moi même a atteint c'est démentiel sakho
mesure comment un animal grand comme ça
peut peser aussi lourd qu'un animal de
cette taille là c'est forcément bidon ça
ne peut être que fo ont peut-être pas
tant que ça si on y réfléchit un peu
déjà comme il n'existe absolument aucun
animal terrestre atteignant la taille
des sauropodes
il existe une probabilité non
négligeable que notre droite de
régression ne soit pas une droite mais
une courbe formant un plateau ce plateau
signifierait qu'arrivé à un certain
poids les contraintes mécaniques
deviennent tellement énorme sur les os
des pattes que leur circonférence se
mettent à croître exponentiellement
à ce niveau le corps parvient de moins
en moins à soutenir le poids de l'animal
et les eaux doivent être incroyablement
plus robustes même pour des
accroissements de masse très faible de
plus les
rtpr des sauropodes les cervicales en
particulier porte les traces de large
sac est rien comme en possède les
oiseaux actuels
c'est très certainement grâce à saissac
aérien que les sauropodes parvenait à
respirer malgré leur long cou car ils
permettent à l'air de suivre un circuit
dans les poumons au lieu de faire de
simples aller retour ce qui évite aux
dinosaures de s'étouffer comme quand on
respire dans un tube à trop long un bon
ben moi qui pensait que l'on coup
c'était juste pour rendre le raid
bending plus épique
on ne sait pas exactement quelle était
l'étendue de ses sacs aérien et les
spécialistes considèrent généralement
qu'ils occupaient de 10 à 30% du volume
de l'animal néanmoins certains oiseaux
actuels ont des sa carrière en puissance
jusqu'à 50% de leur corps imagine si la
moitié de ton braqueurs étaient remplies
d'air comme chez ces oiseaux alors les
30 tonnes qui nous paraissait si
raisonnable tout à l'heure doit être
divisé par deux et pouf qu ashton et
c'est sans compter l'immense intestins
de ces gigantesques herbivores qui
devait agir comme une grande chambre à
fermentation et donc être remplies de
méthane un gaz chauds qui devait encore
alléger le brachiosaure évidemment vu
comme ça un poids de seulement 13 tonnes
ne paraît pas si fou mais encore faut-il
admettre que brachiosaures russe avait
des sax aérien d'oiseaux or pour autant
que je sache les brachiosaures ça vole
pas oui mais justement les oiseaux ne
sont pas de gigantesques monstres qui
doivent pouvoir leur carcasse
gargantuesque au sol alors selon toi les
sauropodes aurait autant eu besoin de
large sac aérien pour se déplacer sur la
terre ferme que les oiseaux n'ont besoin
pour voler oui et si ça se trouve les
sauropodes en avait peut-être même
encore plus besoin
mouais bah permets moi d'être perplexe
quant à cette dernière estimation
alors le brachiosaure seraient en gros
le plus grand des sauropodes par sa
hauteur mais son poids serait parmi les
plus petits et rodelin ce plus grand et
le plus petit est le poids d'un gros
éléphant pour un brachiosaure moi j'y
crois pas alors que propres et si je
propose de passer au niveau supérieur de
passer au high tech d'entrer dans le 21e
siècle bref je propose de passer à la
paléontologie 2.0 d'étudier le vieux
avec ce que l'on fait de plus 9
il est temps de passer à la 5ème méthode
permettant de mesurer le poids du
brachiosaure la plus moderne
il est temps de faire de la
digitalisation 3d je sens que ça va être
compliqué tu m'étonnes que ça va être
compliqué c'est fini les petites
estimations pas cher est faisable par
monsieur et madame tout le monde
ces filles les mesures mètre ruban et au
pied coulisses aux grands maux les
grands remèdes aux grandes questions
micro moyens on prend un scanner
surfacique un échafaudage et on se calme
tout le squelette du brachiosaure de
berlin des pieds à la tête
centimètre carré par centimètre carré
pour enfin avoir un modèle 3d convenable
et finalement savoir combien il pesait
en effet et envoie du lourd
mais si on n'a pas de calais un
surfacique alors on prend un appareil
photo numérique ou un téléphone portable
et on fait ce qu'on appelle de la
photogrammétrie en prenant des photos
des eaux sous toutes les coutures la
technique de photogrammétrie permis de
les reconstituer en 3d sur ordinateur en
se basant sur le phénomène de parallaxe
à là ça sent les grandes études lien ça
sent la science qui se donne les moyens
là ça sent l'ambition est là ça sent la
rigueur scientifique
saül bons les résultats d'une incroyable
précision et de réalisme inégalé chaleur
elle a ralenti dit dis c'est quoi le
résultat 1 la réponse ultime un 10/10
et bien grâce à cette technologie de
pointe et à la 3d il a pu être possible
de déterminer que brachiosaures use
peser entre 38 et 74 tonnes heure 38 74
tonnes bas bonjour la précision
rappelle moi ce qu'on avait obtenu avec
la méthode du plus plouffe les juges ou
un entre entre 30 et et 78 tonnes eh ben
ça valait le coup de se faire suer à
grimper tout là-haut et a passé tout le
squelette au scanner des dents bah là je
comprends pas ça n'a rien à voir avec le
fait qu'il y à deux espèces différentes
de brachiosaures puisqu'on l'a fait que
sur un seul spécimen
elle est où l'erreur là en fait je crois
qu'il n'y a rien à comprendre le
problème des estimations de poids c'est
que ce ne sont que des estimations et
qu'il faut les prendre comme elles sont
des approximations du poids des
extrapolations qui ne sert qu'à avoir
une idée générale du véritable poids du
dinosaure
les fossiles ce sont des eaux et entre
le squelette et les estimations de poids
incluant la chair il ya tout un
processus qui aussi rigoureux soit il
est forcément spéculatifs fait
intervenir les expertises personnelle de
chacun et donc difficilement
reproductibles ses approximations sont
sujettes à toutes sortes d'erreurs des
erreurs de mesure bien sûr mais aussi
des imprécisions dans l'estimation de
l'espace entre les eaux entre les
vertèbres par exemple et des billets
induits par le fait qu'il n'existe aucun
squelette 100% complet la queue du
magnifique squelette de berlin par
exemple appartient à un autre individu
que lui et le brachiosaure d'amérique du
nord n'est en réalité connue que par son
bassin et quelques au tour est fini
brachiosaures il ya mairie de toutes les
tailles des jeunes des adultes des très
vieux et
si des mâles et des femelles ça ne
facilite pas les choses oui d'autant que
les animaux actuels vous et moi inclus
changeons de poids constamment au cours
de notre vie même une fois notre
croissance finit certains primates par
exemple perdre entre 30 et 50 % de leur
masse corporelle en hiver que j'aimerais
être l'un de ces primates et puis dans
le cas du modèle 3d plus
particulièrement ceux qui fait varier
l'estimation de poids c'est le même
facteur que celui qui la faisait varier
avec la figurine
tout dépend de la quantité de chair que
l' on reconstitue sur le modèle
rappelez-vous du dodo de dieu qui
perdaient la moitié de son poids selon
les estimations raclée aux russes c'est
pareil ce n'est rien d'autre qu'un gros
très gros dodo due selon la façon dont
on reconstruit prices aux russes il peut
apparaître avec des proportions très
différentes
la taille des pieds celle de la tête la
longueur du coup font varier
considérablement le volume du modèle
reconstruit et donc le poids de l'animal
à 6 estimé modèle g au delmas que
choisir
et puis il ya les sacs aériens chaque
scientifique y va de sa propre
estimation pour évaluer leur impact sur
le poids final de la bête mais au final
on ne sait pas exactement à quel point
les et contribuer et le problème n'est
pas limité que seuls brachiosaures
giganotosaurus par exemple un carnivore
sud-américain qu'on pense être plus
grand encore que le t-rex un poids
estimé entre 2 et 10 tonnes c'est en
fait une sacrée marge pour dire ce qu'on
veut à propos de sa taille
finalement combien peser le brachiosaure
des nombreuses estimations tournent
généralement autour de 20 à 50 tonnes et
les paléontologues semble plus ou moins
d'accord sur une moyenne qui
avoisinerait les 30 tonnes et pouvant
atteindre 45 comme grand maximum et ça
c'est le résultat d'une centaine
d'années de travail réalisé par une
dizaine de chercheurs
la conclusion à tirer de tout ça c'est
qu'il ne faut pas se jeter avidement sur
les premières estimations de poids venu
quand on parle de dinosaures et
particulièrement de sauropodes
les marges d'erreur sont gigantesques et
la mise en place d' une moyenne
raisonnable pour les estimations prend
du temps beaucoup de temps
ne vous précipitez pas sur les chiffres
gigantesques
tout à fait fascinant de s'imaginer
qu'un animal terrestre et pu atteindre
des dimensions comparables à celles des
baleines bleues mais cela n'avancera en
rien les scientifiques si c'est faux les
estimations de poids chez les espèces
préhistoriques c'est très sexy et tout
le monde en redemande qu'importe leur
qualité alors ne tombez pas dans le
piège
et rappelez-vous que le poids d'un
dinosaure c'est comme les fast-foods
tout le monde aime ça mais vaut mieux
pas savoir comment c'est fait